alors ça c'est ce que vous redoutez tous
ces justes et dernièrement regarder ça
s'appelle une côte et pourtant je vous
assure il n'y a rien à redouter de ça
[Musique]
mais déjà quand on attaque une côte
il faut ralentir ralentir naturellement
parce que le défaut de beaucoup d'entre
vous si vous avez envie de courir dans
la côte à la même vitesse que à laquelle
vous êtes arrivé sur le plat donc ça
c'est possible mais si on commence la
course à pied c'est compliqué alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire donc vous
ralentissez plus que jamais vous vous
tenez droit vous ne vous écrasez pas ce
que dès que ça monte
on a tendance à complètement s'écraser
et a martelé les pas s'enfoncer dans le
sol vous restez bien droit plus que
jamais vous surveillez votre respiration
comme je vous ai déjà montré le 3 3 ou 2
ou alors et puis vous y aller doucement
prenez l'image d'un train qui continue
sa route vous y aller tout doucement
cherchez pas la performance
vous verrez ça passera tout seul à
bientôt pour un nouveau conseil running